If you've gotten this far,
you've done some really cool stuff with
understanding the location and
context of your device.
>From the skills you've learned,
you'll be able to write applications
that know where your phone is,
where it's going, and maybe even
how high off the ground it is.
Now how about we take
it to the next level?
How about an app that tells you when
you enter or leave a specific location?
You could use this for
social checkings, or maybe,
as a parent, you can use this
to tell when your kids get home.
I've even seen games that use this,
where they virtually hide loot, and
when you go to the real world location,
your device knows and can react.
A great and easy way to implement
this is using a geofence.
Simply, a geofence is
a location in latitude and
longitude, a radius around that location
and a time for which it's active.
So for example,
you could put the latitude and
longitude of your lute stash.
A radius of, say, ten meters and
data that is only active on weekends.
The location APIs will take this and
when you exit or
enter that space, it can be used
to generate a notification.
It's up to you, as a developer,
how you handle this.
Does that sound exciting?
Well I think so.
So let's dive in and learn how it works.